what if I told you that your so forth
equals your net worth and the more
confidence and belief you have in
yourself the more successful you'll be
in this video I want to showcase someone
who loses confidence in every single
ounce of his soul and that is rap mogul
Sean Combs otherwise known as Diddy
according to forbes that he has a net
worth of over eight hundred and twenty
million dollars which makes him the
second richest rap recording artist ever
and one of the reasons he was able to
get there is because of his bulletproof
confidence which begs the question how
do you build a millionaire level
unshakable confidence just like Diddy
well you're about to find out in three
easy steps let's get started the first
step to building confidence is to
unapologetically be your biggest fan
that means giving yourself positive
self-talk at all times you have to
realize that the world is not all
sunshine and rainbows not everybody's
going to like you and not everybody
wants you to succeed and it doesn't
matter how nice or caring you are that's
just the name of the game that is why
it's so crucial to surround yourself
with people who want you to succeed the
road to the bag is definitely tied to
your team and the company that you keep
if you are surrounding yourself with
different energies that's not on the
same wavelength as you if they not
praying for you inspiring you supporting
you for showing you a better way hello
remove them immediately or you could
take them to church pray for taking the
church but you can't help them get there
though you got to take care yourself you
know what it's called it's like we
talked about the other day is like being
on an airplane and the thing come down
you got to take care yourself first you
know they put the mask on put the mask
on
but at the same time you should have
base your self-worth on their validation
their confidence to encouragement
because this is just a recipe for a
disaster how come because you'll turn
into a yo-yo of emotions when someone
says something good about you you'll
feel on top of the world you'll feel
unstoppable but the minute somebody says
something negative your confidence is
going way down to rock bottom
do you see how dangerous that could be a
lot of stuff that I say all the time
I know y'all taking that your dad was
hardcore that's cool that is the game
you in I'm sorry that it's a game you
decided to hit it that game is bad way
to tame I like women I don't like just
to win that is why it's so important
that you become your primary source for
positive emotions that means telling
yourself that you deserve success and
that also means that you should be kind
to yourself and embrace and allow good
things to happen to you but that also
means looking at your life and noticing
when you're not doing the things that
you should be doing you can understand I
used to walk around I was telling
presence the other day so walk around
and just talk to myself I like like you
know I'm walking from from one job to
another and I would just be talking to
myself talking about you know the things
that I would I dreamt and I wanted to be
and and and this right here goes out to
the all in people y'all know y'all know
who y'all know who y'all are and y'all
know what I'm talking about you're
talking to yourself and talking and
about how you want to get it and what
you want to be and you know this this is
something that's big being your biggest
fan does not mean that now you become
naive to your problems or your
shortcomings it also does not mean
ignoring things that you should layton
the fix it means treating your self with
respect
putting your happiness first and being
your own personal cheerleader so I would
say tomorrow mindset that you have to
have you definitely have to be a little
crazy
um your your your faith in your belief
has to be crazy you have to you have to
see was not there
and manifested to be in there but the
mindset is that I was a dreamer I was a
dreamer I started this whole thing as a
dream and then the day that I turned
into the combination of a dreamer and a
realist that's when I started to really
go this leads me to the second tip on
how to build millionaire level
confidence and that is to have integrity
with your word now I did not realize how
absolutely important this was until
recently you see I made it a goal to be
more productive and to not use social
media when I was working but somehow I'd
end up on YouTube or Facebook way more
than I'd like to him four hours of time
and every time this would happen I'd
always feel weird inside my mood would
get lower and I'd lose motivation it was
almost as if I was getting the air
knocked out of me I didn't know why this
was happening until I did some more
research and that weird feeling that I
was feeling was my self-esteem taking a
hit why was that because I had lied to
myself I was telling myself I would do
one thing but I ended up doing another
and the more you do this the less belief
you will have in yourself I've
definitely been having like some
personal breakthroughs in my life and
just you know on the man in the mirror
side of things just you know taking
accountability for me being happy for me
being balanced and also me growing as a
person
and I think when you when you get closer
to God you're happier and when you get
closer to the knowledge of yourself and
you're not afraid to go on that journey
to find out how messed up you are how
good you are but your overall result is
that you want to be a better man a
better father than they push you in that
spirit think about an area in your life
where you like integrity with your word
maybe it's your diet your work family if
you told yourself that you were going to
do something and you didn't do it you
are essentially lying to yourself
I'm gonna keep y'all like each other
love each other you get a long hang out
on the weekends know that it's only one
result and as I said my family is to
keep your thoughts and your actions have
to be in total alignment if you don't
take action on the decisions I will
serve or help you whether that's getting
outside your comfort zone facing your
fears or doing the things that you've
been avoiding over time your self-esteem
will take hit after hit after hit until
you're left with zero belief in yourself
that's why integrity is so important I
just wanted to work hard I started my
first job was a paper route when I was
12 I wasn't really old enough to get the
paper route but I worked it out then I
worked in a gas station then I was a
busboy at a Mexican restaurant and I
just I've just worked all my life and
that's why I try to tell people and just
work as hard as you can you know keep
your faith in God all things are
possible to God now for the last tip and
I like to call this the confidence
formula this formula is how to go
confidence anything you want to do this
is how to go from newbie to master this
is what separates those who are filled
with self-confidence and those who reek
of self-doubt no one have goals man I'm
trying to be great yo-yo
[Music]
anybody so here is the confidence
formula courage + competence equals
confidence number one you need to have
the courage to try it no matter what
that thing is even if it means failing
number two you need to get competent or
good at that thing and that means doing
it again and again and number three you
now have the confidence because you've
done the things so many times that you
know how to get the desired result
consistently and that is how you form a
habit and master a skill man um I just
want it I want it more than almost
everybody in here I wanna I wanted more
than almost everybody in here that's
what I'm talking about you gotta stand
up for yourself and be able to compete
that's right and you got to put the work
that it's gonna take to do it I don't
know if you're gonna do the same work as
I'm gonna do I'm gonna read up on it I'm
gonna say they're gonna be like yo let's
go to live tonight be like I'm not gonna
live tonight I gots to get to the back
hey you listen I know let's let's smoke
some I can't now I'm not smoking that
rich all right now I gotta get to the
bag confidence at the end of the day can
only be formed by taking risks and not
being afraid to fail there you go those
are my three biggest tips to build
unshakable confidence just like Diddy go
out and try them right now to recap
number one be your biggest fan
number two have integrity with your word
and number three use the confidence
formula courage + competence equals
confidence this was Edwin Torres from
next-level confidence make sure you
leave a comment below let me know what
your favorite tip was and let me know
what videos you want me to make next
I had fun shooting this video hopefully
you had fun too till next time peace
full volume you have the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon if you want to see edwin's
last breakdown on how to build instant
connection with people like Tony Robbins
does check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there hey this is Edwin Torres and in
this video we're going to break down how
to build instant rapport and connection
with people just like Tony Robbins